welcome to the climate show review of
the year we're going to look back at
some of the highs and lows some of the
heroes and maybe some turkeys and
because it's a festive time of year
there may even be some fun
[Music]
as it's the holidays we've escaped from
the studio and come to a pub and it's
also a time not to be alone and I'm with
our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
welcome thank you it's very joy in here
yeah well we're gonna have a little look
back at the year 2022 it seems to me the
big story this year is energy price
availability
um fuel poverty all those things that
was the theme that absolutely dominated
2022 of course as a result of Vladimir
Putin's legal invasion of Ukraine
driving a global energy crisis and
there's a couple of different responses
to that across the world there were
those Nations who went right the climate
change agenda can wait we need to find
our own fossil fuels our own secure
sources of energy let's burn more coal
let's dig for more oil and gas and then
there were other nations who said we now
know for sure we cannot rely on Russia's
hydrocarbons that's a big problem the
only way out of this mess is to
accelerate investment in Renewable Power
and clean power well I'll be making a
little film looking at that and talking
to some of the people on the front line
of this
foreign
twenty two was the year renewable energy
made its case more loudly than ever as
the supply of oil and gas faltered and
its price rocketed cheaper home-grown
green Alternatives made sense even if
you care solely about cash not climate
press the left dial in once I then
scroll to user profile the fossil fuel
price hikers triggered a dash from gas
and Joe and Ash are Front Runners a
recent survey suggested the number of
green jobs advertised had traveled in
the last year
they're training on heat pumps and
energy-saving electric alternative to
central heating boilers this company
alone has 40 000 customers on the
waiting list I was a kitchen engineer
for last 16 17 years I was an English
teacher at secondary school for about 15
years and then switched to Plumbing why
did you make the change realizing
people's uh dreams of of love being
green in the future and that is
important for our families as well I've
got young kids that are obviously
thinking about this is the kind of
feel-good side of this matter a bit to
you as well 100 means everything when
you've got a tough day and you're
thinking I'm actually doing something
positive it does matter yeah and what is
it now that's spreading the enthusiasm
of the heat pumps I think basically it's
spreading by word of mouth so we've got
the last month we've been doing heat
pumps for the same family we've heard
about people having heat pump parties
after we've put the heat pump in and
then neighbors go around and then we
might get a call in a couple of weeks
afterwards and a fair wind behind
Renewables is being felt worldwide in
the first half of 2022 gas prices shot
up at their peak in June nearly three
times the normal level they've come down
a bit since but they are still around
twice the normal price oil too has
nearly doubled in value at some times in
2022 and all that made fossil fuels far
less attractive than renewable energies
so I guess this is the sort of thing
you'd like to see yeah it's pretty
impressive array the International
Energy agency is seeing a step change in
green power deployment saying the world
is set to add as much Renewable Power in
the next five years as it did in the
previous 20. so at last roofs like this
are becoming the norm in the past is it
fair to say you were partly sort of
pushing saying we need to do this
because we have to care whereas now it's
the finance director saying this stuff
makes sense oh absolutely no the
economic case is there everybody was
worried about payback how long 10 15
years but we've seen payback two three
years really pay back yeah payback's
that's worth yeah I think the biggest
area though is everybody realizing about
Energy Efficiency and we have to say
that's got to be first using not using
the energy that we we desperately need
what's your prediction for 2023 I think
by the end of 2023 we'll see that more
than half of our electricity will be
coming from Renewable Power sources
across that year it'll be more than half
renewable yep I think so the energy
Supply crisis triggered by war in
Ukraine stoked fears of blackouts and
freezing homes so many governments look
to shore up the grid with any sources of
power halting closure plans for Coal
Power stations and here incentivizing
new Drilling in the North Sea but not
even industry Representatives see a
long-term fossil Revival we're not going
to see an explosion into investing in
fossil fuels quite the reverse we're
looking to see how we can manage our
decline in a way which helps keep the
lights on in the UK so despite the
higher prices making in some ways
economically more attractive to do this
and there is some government incentive
for exploration you're saying despite
those things you're not seeing a big
Dash to fossil fuels I'm pleased to say
no one expects the current high prices
to Prevail for decades to come we're in
the middle of a price bubble and that's
that's the big challenge that's what's
driving the UK that's the really
important point that I'm just getting
from you is that the industry is not
treating this high price of fossil fuels
as the norm going forward last not no
thank goodness not as well because it's
simply not a way for society to live if
the oil and gas industry really are
planning their own demise the bumper
profits of 2022 could be their last
hurray
I find this quite confusing but also
fascinating you can paint 2022 as either
a setback in the fight against climate
change or potentially a great asset I
guess it depends whether you're a kind
of half full or half empty kind of
person I tend to be more optimistic
about it what do you think what do you
think 2023 holds I'm optimistic too
because organizations like the
International Energy agency has said
pretty categorically that although there
might be a short-term leap in the use of
fossil fuels as people burn more coal or
consider burning more coal to keep the
lights on as they're doing in Europe for
example long term it's become
commercially beneficial
to invest in renewable energy sources
and that means that we're going to add
more renewable energy capacity in the
next five years than we did in the last
20 potentially so that's really really
good news I also think people are going
to get excited about nuclear again ah
that'll be very interesting I mean I put
it to the fossil fuel guy that this was
kind of the last hurray for his industry
he wasn't quite having that but there
was a from him at least it was a
suggestion that you know they
acknowledged the downslope is there and
maybe what's happened in Ukraine has
made that slopes deeper yeah I think
there is a broad acknowledgment in the
fossil fuel industry that they might be
printing money right now and in the next
couple of years but broadly they're
looking at how to get rid of stranded
assets over the next 10 to 20 years you
know rigs in the North Sea are going to
lose their value very rapidly that's a
declining basin
but there is another side to this right
80 of our Global energy generation comes
from fossil fuels it's not a dead
industry yet and I think also sometimes
the fossil fuel industry is is helped
want of a better word when we have very
still weather and people start panicking
about wind in particular and we've seen
that play out in the years yeah and of
course one thing that high oil and gas
prices do is they make some sort of
exploration viable that wasn't viable
before and we're seeing that and we'll
see in the short term absolutely right
and that's why Rishi sunak is still
pushing ahead with granting a hundred
more licenses in the North Sea at one
point Liz truss was thinking about
fracking wasn't she there's this focus
on securing domestic reliable energy
sources but also because nations are
hedging their bets we're looking at huge
acceleration of investments in wind
power and so on it's just more energy
all around exactly right
well one thing that happened for me in
2022 was thanks to my excellent
producers I made my day beyond tick tock
retrofitting is the avoidance of
building new buildings and that's good
because constructing things involves so
much concrete steel all those figures
they belch a lot of carbon so if you can
refurbish rather than rebuild that's
three times better for the climber
how's that that's perfect it's your
first tip took the sky
well we're going to stick with the
social media theme now but with a quiz
because no Christmas period is complete
without one and our quiz Master is Ollie
Frost who makes climate films with Tick
Tock tell me about
um well I make novelty songs about the
climate crisis and they tell stories
about climate change from the point of
view of vampires Pirates Cowboys Greta
tunberg wanted a remake of one of your
songs yeah the first song I did was
called the Greta turnberg song and she
she made a remake of the video she does
the Macarena in it
right we're gonna get on with the quiz
crack on there one thing I haven't told
you the loser gets to wear the turkey
hat I know it's gonna fit you well
okay which of these things from the song
The 12 Days of Christmas has the most
emissions is it a eight major milking B
five gold rings or c a partridge in a
pear tree made to milk they also was
gold rings
in November the UN announced it will
start naming and shaming the sources of
methane leaks around the world how will
they know where the leaks are coming
from is it a a new space satellite
system nickname Mars an undercover
methane Hunter nicknamed Santa or is it
by incentivizing businesses and
communities to report leakers using a
system called grass local satellites
satellites is correct balance
this year's finest for the comedy
Wildlife photography awards what are
some of the best yet but which picture
took home the trophy was it a these
sassy Penguins B this completely
oblivious Harem or was it C this clumsy
cat oh Heron cat
and the answer was the cat
um Jennifer Hadley won with the picture
she said the cat was fine slipping away
from me no injuries for the cat and to
wrap up how many miles of wrapping paper
do britons use each year is it a naught
to 100 000 B 100 000 to 200 000 or 200
000 to 300 000 no 200 000.
100 000 to two hundred thousand for the
answer was two hundred thousand to three
hundred thousand I
we answered 227 yeah yeah why not yeah
yeah
oh we have to um we have to run there
okay
that means you win I did I
get to wear the headgear
we're into a break now Hannah and I will
be back uh later on to talk about some
of our highlights from 2022 and also
with a special guest to talk about
what's coming in 2023
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show review
of the year in a moment we'll get stuck
into chat about what happened but first
let's remind ourselves of some of the
events
loss and damage can no longer be swept
under the rug the momentous occasion for
us lovely Recycling and electronics it's
shockingly low they're now almost back
to 40 000.
you can smell it the ash blowing through
the air the trees that are still smoking
I had no time to feel sorry to be
fearful all I knew is I had to move fast
we're making the largest investment ever
in clean energy
right now every government in the world
is off course black smoke filling them
everywhere with all the Emergency
Services Fusion ignition this is one of
the most impressive scientific Feats of
the 21st Century
well to mull over the events of 2022
with our mulled wine Hannah and I have
been joined by Angela Francis from WWF
welcome thanks coming thanks nice to be
in the pub with you guys
um for me I mean the one thing that
stands out about 2022 is record
temperatures like we have never seen in
the UK before big deal for reporters
like Hannah and I what about for you
yeah the temperatures the droughts the
floods they all came across our desk at
WWF I mean it was It was kind of insane
like you know the climate crisis has
been warning about it was happening
around us and you know we were we were
ready to respond that was one good thing
but it was it's not what you wanted to
happen and we didn't want to see the
type of weather and the events we saw
yeah and indeed Hannah for you you were
overseas quite a lot because this wasn't
of course just Britain this was
worldwide Europe particularly yeah and
the you know the last eight years uh are
likely to have been the hottest on
record we saw that play out in real time
as you were saying and in Europe in
Portugal and Spain in particular they
suffered in absolutely brutal heat and
wildfires and I think it got me about
those stories was that there was a
crisis to deal with the immediate public
health effects of Heat and the fires and
the loss of homes and the emergencies
but then there's this awful ripple
effect issues with crops you know the
ground drying out and people thinking
about whether or not they'd want to live
in their communities anymore and even
here in the UK these wildfires didn't
just affect the wild lands they burned
Villages too didn't they it really is an
example of how vulnerable we are in the
face of climate change even in a country
that has felt relatively safe up until
this moment it was it was this extreme
heat impacting us in a way we'd never
really experienced before
well you and I both worked a lot on on
climate this year we've got some of the
props on the table of stories that I've
done the stuff about rock dust coal soil
even though the copper pipe made some
relevance as well but but tell me Hannah
about the stories that that you
particularly enjoyed doing or you
thought were really instructive well I
time talking about bad
world
solution and it's it's Sweden they've
come up with a way to make green steel
replacing coking coal with green
hydrogen because they have a lot of
green electricity so they're able to do
it and it solved a really critical
problem because steel globally it was
wonderful for about eight percent of
global emissions
this is a traditional way of making
steel it involves using a blast furnace
burning coal and emitting a lot of
carbon dioxide in the process and it's
why Global steel manufacturing Accounts
at eight percent of carbon emissions
but that is on the cusp of changing
less than a mile away a modern
alternative is taking shape
a group of companies have worked out how
to swap coal for hydrogen gas
eliminating the dirtiest bit of the
steel making process we started this in
2016 it was in some cases perceived like
a kind of a crazy idea but I mean now
six years later we we come tremendously
far I mean it actually works
you have Solutions in your title is that
something that WF gets involved in as
well yeah we're really supporting
government being really clear on how we
move industry and Manufacturing to Net
Zero it's one of the things that we need
to do is reduce emissions as well as
providing carbon sinks which is the
other thing that WF does so much work on
well I had quite a few few films that I
enjoyed making this year as Hannah and I
know it's basically first we'll look
cool when it comes to making films out a
good one with rock dust walking through
clouds of of Ash and things like that
but this actually is a clue to something
I particularly enjoyed um we did a film
about offsetting carbon offsetting and
of course we had to choose a car rally
that was offsetting in order to
illustrate this story well
oh my God
[Music]
oh well
the other big thing of course 2022 huge
political change here and what had what
did that mean to you in your business I
mean we're looking for real consistent
messages from politicians so they can
tell businesses and communities what's
going to happen to them and we got none
of that we we had things moving you know
left right and center with every new
prime minister and it's it's been really
difficult I mean the thing that I I draw
sort of positive messages from is the
fact that when governments wanted to
start fracking or wasn't delivering on
the Energy Efficiency we needed we got
really strong support from the public
and from businesses and we got things
back on course so we still got real
concerns around
um the fact that um offshore when um
that the fact that um windfall taxes for
oil and gas have got these big loopholes
in them which encourage investment in
more extraction which makes no sense and
then we've had the recent Cumbria um
Coal Mine decision which is just draw
dropping really but
um yeah we I think those things are
going to be um increasingly pushed out
by um
Charities book business and and
communities saying that they just don't
want that and what have you witnessed
the political roller coaster I think
you'd be forgiven for having Whiplash
wouldn't you over the last 12 months you
know we had you know there's a
Resurgence of fracking under under Liz
trust and that fell away Andrea sunak
and then he was interested still in
expanding exploration in the North Sea
but at the same time accelerating
investments in in wind farms a lot of
these sort of signals rather than actual
changes of policy you know fracking
never actually quite happened you know
some of the things that wind farms
there's a lot of talk but actually on
the ground I'm not sure how much changes
which has confused people I think it has
been quite confusing particularly for
business who are looking for a stable
environment to invest in and it's sort
of a long time Horizon when you're
talking about billions of pounds worth
of investment they need to know where
it's going and then the windfall tax
back and forth actually made it more
confusing for them as well and it's
difficult for renewable energy providers
to know how much money to put into wind
farms and they also going to have to
calculate whether or not they have to
pay massive tax when they get a profit
from their generation has been really
complicated and then of course we had
the cop 27 the the climate Summit in
Egypt would Rishi soon go as the new
prime minister or not we had
vacillations on on that I mean it was
Willy Wonky wasn't it I mean it was I
thought that was quite embarrassing I
don't know about you for us we were glad
he went in the end but when he came back
it wasn't really clear that government
had understood that Environmental
Protection and you know delivering for
the economy went hand in hand we still
have this feeling that some of the
things that are still at risk
deregulating removing Environmental
Protections slowing down all the support
for Farmers to move to Nature friendly
farming those are things are all still
on the table so it's not really clear
that he went to cop and came back with a
really clear message of what that meant
for the UK well let's move on to what
might be happening in 2023 uh prediction
from you well 2023 I think if we've had
a year for the last couple of years or
three year slogans we would like to see
2023 slogan B keep your promises keep
your promises on climate keep your
promises on restoring nature keep your
promises on ending deforestation keep
your promises on no trade deals that
undercut UK farming transition that's
what we're asking government to do great
well we asked a few of the people who've
contributed to the program over the year
to give us their thoughts about what
might happen in 2023
what I'm most looking out for in 2023 is
what impact that the global weather
phenomenon called El Nino might have on
our climate I'm also more locally
interested to see whether the UK
government will deliver on its promise
to make UK homes and buildings much more
energy efficient my prediction for 2023
is that cop 28 will be pivotal as the
UAE seeks to increase its soft power
that green hydrogen investment will
continue to grow and that ESG importance
will explode as companies use it as a
tool for employee retention we'll see
issues around availability and security
sharpening people's minds we'll see
progress on hydrogen the word
electrolyzer will become more widely
known and I think we'll see the first
transatlantic flight with a large
airplane on 100 sustainable aviation
fuel the energy crisis will accelerate
the global shift to Renewables 2023
we'll see the switch on the first phase
of dog Bank the world's biggest wind
farm that will eventually power 6
million UK homes but when the wind
doesn't blow and snow is covering solar
panels we are still reliant on gas and
that needs an urgent solution
my climate prediction for 2023 is that
enhanced Rock weathering will take the
carbon removal Space by storm now it's a
nature-based technology that's rapid
scalable and permanent and can lock up
to 10 gigatons of carbon dioxide per
year I am optimistic that in 2023
223 new species will be saved from
Extinction I believe that together we
can realize this goal
[Music]
well the thoughts of some of our guests
that just leaves you and me now Hannah
prediction I think that 1.5 degrees of
warming is going to hang in the balance
as governments burn more fossil fuels
and I think as a result the protest
movements that have sprung up going to
get even more radical well I have an
optimistic one which is that in 2023 we
might actually see carbon capture and
storage all that stuff that comes on off
from fossil fuels actually happen in the
UK fingers crossed well you can catch up
with more of this on the climate cast on
Sky News but for now just remains so one
more thing from our Pub and that has to
be cheers
foreign